[موسيقى]
باكستان هي بلد
تعاملنا في مع الكثير من الازمات منذ
منتصف الثمانينات فالمحزن ان نقول اننا
نقدم ونوفر الحمايه لاجيال من الافغان
واحيانا نرى الاجداد الذين نقدم لهم
المساعده بعد تقديم المساعده
لابنائهم واحفادهم فهؤلاء اجيال من
الافغان يحصلون على المساعدات
[موسيقى]
فقد دعمنا حوالي ثلاثين مستشفى في
افغانستان من خلال تقديم رواتب
الدكاتره والاطباء والممرضين ونواصل
القيام بذلك لان هذا امر حيوي بالنسبه
للافغان
وكذلك يشمل عملنا
عمل عمل اللجنه الدوليه لاساليب الاحمر
زياره السجناء ونواصل القيام بذلك كما
اننا نحاول بدل قصار جهدنا لتوفير سبل
العيش فقلت فان اجيال تعول على المساعدات
الانسانيه من
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
[موسيقى]
لقد عبرنا عن قلقنا بعد القرارات التي
اتخذت في اعقاب شهر ديسمبر من العام
الماضي وما قمنا به هو اننا تعاونا مع
السلطات في افغانستان لضمان ان كافه
الموظفات يمكن لهن ان تواصلنا عملهن كما
فعلتنا من قبل وهذا ما هو عليه الحال ومن
جانب اخر نحن نحرس على ضمان ان في
المستشفى التي ندعمها وان في
المدارس التدريب
الطبي التي نمولها ان يكون هناك نساء ايضا
يعملن في هذه المؤسسات
[موسيقى]